e se vi dicessi che questi sono bucatini
all'amatriciana
io non so che chi indovina tecia è più
la facciata a cuba
no bruciatura nicola
perfetto cielo ragazzi siamo oggi in
compagnia dei two men walking è un
canale che io adoro particolarmente di
cosa vi occupate che noi facciamo cose
che sono altre cose però anch'io e ci ho
fatto carriera diciamo che la cosa
pazzesca vostra e che voi riuscite a far
bere piatti di pasta riuscite a far
masticare cocktail la cosa pazzesca è
che voi siete bravissimi nella cucina
molecolare quindi trasformate la materia
e mettete consistenze alle quali
solitamente non è abituato che oggi
proviamo a fare quello che fate
perfettamente ossia trasformare un
piatto di pasta all'amatriciana in un
perché riscontrate burro un pannello e
marghera ma che alla fine
cessano di fette biscottate pure
marmellata o sanno di una matrice male
madrid
[Musica]
partiamo subito non vedo l'ora di fa di
vedere quello che fate quindi dove siamo
iniziate fanno pure tra qualcosa fare io
ho subito io taglio di cominciare
sopravvisse metto il grembiule tanto ten
alsina paglia e lui che cucina da questa
realtà questo aveva capito tutto
avremo bisogno quindi gli ingredienti
della madre quindi basta
guanciale brodaglia dalla nonna io
questo su chi della nonna ad esempio è
tipo dopo un mese che ci mettiate in
fiera dentro che cos'è sta roba di
pomodoro praticamente quando si fa la
passata si mette in un panno e tutta
l'acqua in eccesso accumulare questo è
il risultato
questa è concentrato giusto e concentra
della nonna ricordi di gioventù della
nostra lei poi aglio cipolla scusate e
poi cesto barattolo bianco cos'è che non
cosio che è il glucosio quest'anno
sciroppo di questo zucchero che ci
servirà per fare una marmellata però
senza avere il gusto dolce ok l'abbiamo
e dobbiamo fare perché dobbiamo estrarre
il grasso dal lanciare
trapani
celine ed il wii mentre io taglio gli si
legge in faccia alla voglia
sulla fronte
prendermi il coltello e tagliare come
lui taglierebbe ecco il cubo
lui sta morendo dentro quanto essere il
fuoco per abbassa medio bassa fino a
quando si schierasse perfetto tante non
farlo bruciare questo è giustissimo ce
lo andiamo a utilizzare il grasso quindi
un buonissimo
poi che devo fare
scoliamo lanciare lo mettiamo entrate
torinese trucco e rimuovere la parola
parte nociva cioè non è che devi scola
regga il grasso del colle e tralascio
per inclinato in modo che nel frattempo
mentre lo spingo magari si trovi da
recarsi qualcosa per grassetto ok
abbiamo questa da mettere da parte e gli
è valsa bisogna salarla l'acqua preserva
la
500 grammi 500 grammi leva su 100 grammi
si servono solo certo cento grazie
ok non so come sia successo poi 500 io
sto per dire una cosa molto forte a me i
bucatini non piacciono
è questo qui era il cuore di alcuni
romani alcuni quanto ci andrebbero una
presa appena ci siamo ragazzi e
ragazzi l'ho assaggiata e terribile
scotta insipida cotta l'orrore proprio
reparto geriatria ampi a 80 anni maniero
a questa il bug a frullare bello o
comunque ragazzi il suono sembrava la le
acque che si rompono quando di partorire
ma pensa che pasta scotta allora siamo
qui con la nostra planetaria pesiamo la
regola se manteniamo un grano duro per
questa pasta mezzo chilo e mezzo di
d'andata mezzo chilo di simona tale
zucchero e limone e limoni non sa 10
questi quanti saranno hicks di ieri su
dieci grammi di ronchey
presa semplicemente il grasso inizia
veramente ad avere delle difficoltà come
che alessandro ragazzi per fare
chiarezza ora stiamo facendo l'impasto
per la fetta biscottata giusto è giusto
gianmarco e ragione si capisce più caps
vero stiamo andando a mettere tutto
insieme ti diverte ma io trovo
il nonno io starei così a guardarlo per
ore siamo tanti siamo didattico
ma guarda che bello che scusa eh posso
giocarmi tutto ecco
non ci credo ma questa è una bolla
polare ma come mai si è creata per la
particolarmente
appiccico non potevo e manualità che mai
ha
già fallito
così perfetto la
resa conto di un cazzo evitiamo che
siamo qua in mezzo due potere del
montaggio è passato un'ora e mezza in
tutto questo
vabbè è cambiato sembra un'altra cosa
oddio adesso che è passata un'ora e
mezza che cosa dobbiamo fare abbiamo
formativa in oggetto di semolino così
tanto mamma mia che tocca a te pare
natale questa è la famosa maglia clou di
nicosia dove la tocco mancato chi allora
si allunga da una parte serie riello s'è
allungata s piega si e poi a rotoli
sempre spingendo un pochino tarena
cappella vada
questo si chiama semi in panificazione
davvero proposito di vedi a proposito di
cappella e lo lasciamo lievitare ancora
il tavolo retta e mezzo e poi e poi si
cuoce quando torno dipende da sempre dal
panetto che facciamo queste campane
grancia riaprì le variabili ragazzi
questo pacchetto che abbiamo fatto noi
oggi come oggi in cui del veneto che
abbiamo fatto oggi e variabili al 35 40
minuti diventa da forno quell'aria
quanti gradi dammi un grado dicevamo
175 all'inizio poi abbassiamo sushi bar
cini carica non lo farete mai
giocato 36 ore e mezzo ok
170 per mera 70 per circa 35 40 o
lo cotto con le mie stesse mani guardalo
non ci credo ragazzi
bellissimo ma possiamo vedere come è
venuto ancora in caldo ora che camorra
che il calcio d'angolo via siamo in
forno queste fette biscottate a quanto e
per quanto già 140 150 gr di forno
ventilato per diciamo che lo ha chiesto
dalle asciutta e mele vocati diciamo hai
detto tutto non ha detto nulla perché
così non esistono bene la famosa matrice
finalmente il suo passaggio ma chi e chi
mamma mia che orrore
certo non sai che terrebbe assegnati al
pomodoro sì però
questo è come amalgamare c'è questo è un
bloody mary the capito
con la viveri marino non te ne pentirai
non te ne pentirai
assaggia shot tardano pallido e palme
solo succo non te ne pentirai
cambierei idea subito aspetta guarda una
muta la faccia
allora è buono non è male inizialmente
mi fa un po impressione ma poi è
veramente un pomodoro e punto vendita
ragione veniva prima di questo dovremo
motivo trita la cipolla ha detto ciò io
questo vita ha insegnato
[Applauso]
che pure sa che palle però certa ma una
volta che tipo a posto così bella e
nobile che pure ha comunque ragazzi si
sente che il tempo sta passando perché i
ragazzi poi state vedendo ovviamente una
versione super montata veloce noi stiamo
qua da mesi a vela smettiamo di fare
agli altri glielo dici che non serve non
ebbe di cazzo
sarà comunque stampa tutte cose comode
oggi
tu sei così sopra un tailleur e
io sono qui da stamattina che dettaglio
tagliolini sottobicchieri c'è lui che
sta su un metro per un metro di terra
vedere così
sì questo è il suo contributo quanto 30
grammi qualcuna età quella youth entro
ok poi così prodigo ok concetto del como
dove vai
girmi due potevano futuro quale
[Musica]
abbiamo di preparazioni lunghi set e lo
credo e lo credo metti il glucosio
oddio ho letto nella rapina
credo che devi facciamo con queste sono
quello che vi dirà finalmente lo dire
diviso in quattro
ma per favore le ragadi mi sono uscite
tre grandi eventi ma perché lo vediamo
un pò in gioco lo show l'hanno capito
che soltanto quando arrivava questa è la
retina età serve nel mare oppure va
nella de pure lei non ho mai usato la
pectina le fanno
attenzione è successo qualcosa
non ci credo risultato sono biscottate
cioè non è pane tostato no no no
soffitti biscottate
in questo momento è il guanciale
o cielo
64 anni titanic era
il più potente ragazzi è dura è dura
siamo passati all'ultima preparazione
appare un burro vinto di pecorino avrà
bisogno pecorino acqua e polvere bianche
come al solito ma cosa stai fuori ma
basta che cos'è questo nome la cappa
dono e makhackala fatto che è
un'avversaria verifica di come sto qua
la stessa cosa in combo perché perché
vogliamo la struttura solida ma elastica
questo è il solito quelle la chiarissima
oddio santo questo sabato passato io a
dargli
grande grande posso riposarmi un attimo
guarda il rapper farlo sto per dire io
perché c'è poi finisce che presenta le
rovini questo è il pecorino questa
piccola grattugiata zelarino ma vedremo
qui sì perché dobbiamo frullarle
così senza niente lavoro dobbiamo
sbrigare in tasca
qualcosa mi stai facendo ecco cosa stai
trovando in questo momento soddisfazione
se volete alla fine assaggiamo
assaggiamo andiamo a preparare il nostro
piatto ragazzo abbiamo qui la nostra
fetta biscottata fatta con dei
bucatini bucatini abbiamo qui
all'interno di questa canapa che abbiamo
tessuto i nuovi real voi non avete visto
che l'abbiamo l'ho fatta e va in 300
fuori camera faccio tutto loro non
stanno facendo un cazzo esatto ma non ci
credo ragazzi questo qui invece è un
burro morbido ip curino guardatelo qui
io cosa faccio p eh
no si reca più piace il pecorino o non
vuoi mettere le vostre quantità non
rompete i [ __ ] a me io e te sono
sette anni che sto fiscali
via domani da cinque mesi perché stiamo
qui ha preparato e adesso passiamo alla
marmellata di io comunque abbondo nel
senso che nel dubbio non soltanto nel
senso a voi fate marmellata cioè le
stesse calorie di un piatto proprio sito
matrice proprio nel codice
sembrano i pallini delle fragole con i
pezzi di frutta dentro c nei ragazzi cn
è stato un onore
avete mai fatto 5 con la matriciana ma
mai usato le brevi un bicchiere passato
ne faremo a meno
salute
[Musica]
non c'è tutta la mattina tutto una
consistenza della marmellata è pazzesca
dai voto da 1 a 10 alta ma diciamo no
perché 10 in uno da nessuno ma il nome
voi che voto date 8 meno
ragazzi sono gli agguati di questo video
infatti inciampato che vedere
seguiteci qui sotto vi lascio sia i link
dei ragazzi menù anche chen che voi link
nostri cazzo ne frega se l'è già coppia
insomma mangiarli sapete noi ci vediamo
domenica prossima alle 12 con una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata ma mi
raccomando qua sotto
fateci sapere quali sono altre cose
strane che questi due ragazzi potrebbero
creare ragazzi ciao
[Applauso]
[Musica]